vollständiger impfschutz so steht es
auch hier in meinem digitalen in fast
vollständiger impfschutz das bedeutete
für mich bisher im grunde corona vorbei
alle freiheiten aber das ist so nicht
mehr das stimmt so nicht mehr denn
selbst wenn man beide pixar hat bedeutet
das jetzt nicht mehr automatisch dass
man vollständigen impfschutz hat das
sagt er hier das sagt merkels
kanzleramtschef helge braun und das ist
ein echter im hammer dass er das sagt
denn das bedeutet im grunde dass ich als
vollständig geimpft bald wieder
behandelt werden könnte wie ein
ungeimpfter und dabei war erst doch mit
seiner regierung der immer wieder gesagt
hat das ist jetzt nur noch eine krone
pandemie der ungeimpften mit diesen mit
seinen eigenen worten werde ich ihnen
jetzt konfrontieren hierbei hat aber
weise
corona ist weg zumindest wenn sie
geimpft sind das war doch immer die
botschaft der bundesregierung in den
vergangenen monaten haben wir noch mal
rein wir bekommen die gefahr eine brandl
ide ungeimpften pandemie der ungeimpften
es ist eine pandemie der ungeimpften der
leben gerade vor allem eine pandemie der
um games panamedia ungeimpften hat die
bundesregierung also immer wieder in den
vergangenen monaten gesagt aber das war
ein irrtum denn mittlerweile landen
immer mehr geimpfte in den
krankenhäusern auf den intensivstationen
corona ist also wieder für alle da das
ist jetzt auch wieder eine pandemie der
geimpften darüber habe ich mit helge
braun gesprochen mit dem kanzleramtschef
das hat man so manchmal den eindruck
weil man von impft durchbrüchen jetzt so
viel hört aber es ist in der tat weiter
so dass impfen schützt enorm gut unsere
impfstoffe sind richtig gut mein
individuelles risiko wenn ich doppelt
geimpft bin einen schweren verlauf zu
haben sinkt um fast 90 prozent aber
moment mal wenn corona jetzt immer mehr
auch geimpfte trifft wenn mein doppelter
impfschutz bald möglicherweise ausläuft
abläuft und wenn man dann auch noch
sieht dass geimpfte das virus im grunde
genauso weitergeben können an andere wie
ungeimpfte dann ergibt das doch mit 3g
und 2g also das aussortieren von
ungeimpften überhaupt keinen sinn oder
sie müssen es so sehen wenn sie drei
leute jeden tag in der restaurant
reinlassen davon sind dann immer zwei
geimpft und eine ungeimpfte
und dann haben sie jeden tag das risiko
wenn sie nichts machen dass einer davon
alle infiziert wenn das nur geimpfte
sind die wahrscheinlichkeit dass einer
dabei ist der andere infiziert mit ihren
fünften tag gegeben aber sie wissen von
keinem haben sie tests eingesammelt
vorher das wäre doch die sichere
variante es ist durch der ungeimpfte
getestete der ist doch in dem moment
viel sicherer als der geimpfte
ungetestet das ist genau falsch also der
der geimpfte der normal geimpfte
zweifach geimpft ist für mich als am
potenziellen infektions empfänger
weniger gefährlich als der der nun
schnell test gemacht hat besser oder
ähnlich ist es wenn ich einen pcr-test
macher sondern bord ist natürlich sehr
teuer ist und natürlich ist es die
optimale sicherheit wenn ich den
geimpften noch zusätzlich testen und
deshalb sozusagen müssen wir jetzt im
winter überlegen wir sind durch den
herbst gekommen mit der 3g regelung also
genesen oder getestet und jetzt wo wir
erkennbar merken dass das im winter
trotzdem nicht nur zur hohen
infektionszahlen sondern einer echten
belastung im gesundheitswesen führt muss
man dann eben überlegen macht man eine
regelung wo man labortests verlangt
macht man eine regelung wo ungeimpfte
nicht teilnehmen können und die dann
weitestgehend variante ist natürlich
dass die geimpften auch noch einen test
machen müssen also der kanzleramtschef
will weiter aussortieren die ungeimpften
in restaurants in fußballstadien zum
beispiel und jetzt kommt jetzt gibt es
einen hochrangigen mediziner den chef
der uniklinik leipzig nämlich professor
josten und er sagt es könnte jetzt
demnächst auch dazu kommen dass selbst
in krankenhäusern ungeimpfte aussortiert
werden nämlich zum beispiel auf der
intensivstation weil da immer mehr die
geimpften mit den ungeimpften um die
knappen ressourcen kämpfen professor
josten der sagt dass geimpfte
konkurrieren um behandlungsplätze mit
nicht geimpften dass eine ethische
fragestellungen die ich so nicht
beantworten kann aber die relativ
schnell aufs tableau kommen kann wenn
wir an unsere an unserer endet unsere
ressourcen kommen es wird ein kampf
geben in den krankenhäusern um die
ressourcen zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften stimmt das wird das zu
kommen und dann entscheidet sich ob man
den ungeimpften erst mal liegen lässt
und erst den geimpften behandelt so dass
es ein szenario das ist natürlich wenn
man nichts macht nicht ausgeschlossen
aber genau deshalb muss es sein es kommt
nicht in frage eine solche situation
dürfen wird deutschlandweit unser
gesundheitswesen niemals bringen das ist
ja ethisch überhaupt nicht zu vertreten
und das ist ein sehr viel
schwerwiegender eingriff in unsere
persönliche freiheit und unsere
körperliche unversehrtheit als die
einschränkungen über die wir ja reden
nämlich die die frage unseres
freizeitverhaltens und anders und
deshalb um genau sowas zu vermeiden
müssen wir jetzt in der politik darüber
reden welche zusätzlichen
vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie er den erbsen
aber das halten sie nicht für ein
absolutes horrorszenario das ist schon
richtig der mann hat die intensivstation
gerade voll und die normalen station
auch mit vielen ungeimpften corona
patienten aber auch eben mit vielen
geimpften krone patienten und er sagt
das wird zu einer konkurrenzsituation
kommen und dann muss man ethische
entscheidung trifft das heißt eine
triage zu lasten von ungeimpften ich
habe ja mit der bild zeitung über die
frage von horrorszenarien in den letzten
wochen auch immer schon sehr viel
kontakt müssen weil sie die immer in die
welt gesetzt haben die horrorszenarien
sehen sie und jetzt ist der unterschied
zwischen szenarien prognose 1 1 was ist
ein horrorszenario das was dein schild
deshalb sage ich das darf nicht eintritt
triage also zwischen geimpften und
ungeimpften die einen die geimpften
werden noch behandelt und die anderen
die ungeimpften fallen hinten runter was
für ein erschreckendes und abstoßendes
szenario was für eine schlimme debatte
die die bundesregierung begonnen hat sie
hat mit 2g und 3g für eine solche
debatte tür und tor geöffnet